[Musique]
histoires drôles sur un perroquet mais
je patiente
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est lui le terme à chris paul ou l'a
fait de façon claire et intelligible
expression qu'elle se passe par ici et
c'est alors il faut qu'elle soit drôle à
peu près quand c'est drôle tout passe à
20 sauf que ça va passer
ah non c'est celle du bar non non non
non à l'accord des pierres lancées plus
grave le corps à ce rythme là et c'est
vraiment du lot a lancé vendredi des
termes choisis vous rappellons nous
sommes deux démissions saint vidal en
termes choisis il m'avait donné on est
très fort en ménagère ça va être dur
[Rires]
être extrêmement sévère sur des choses
qui pourraient dépasser vos pensées
c'est parti alors c'est une femme qui
est très sensible à la cause des animaux
avec ses deux filles et cachette à
perroquets et l'a achetée dans un bordel
qu'à fermer la petite ville de province
où ils habitent parce que là le board
est fermé le perroquet qui est un peu le
symbole l'emblème d'un mascotte du
bordel il fallait récupérer donc elle le
prend dans la maison et le perroquet
tout l'après-midi arrête pas d un fait
la [ __ ] espèce de [ __ ] à la femme est et
où deux filles comme ça donc la merde un
peu marre même si elle est à vous faites
comme un père l'a donc tout l'après-midi
spa ce courriel mais le père de famille
qui rentrent le soir il sort du boulot
et il arrive je la fais courte et
perroquets gris
la nouvelle pub et c'est toujours les
mêmes clients ayant un esprit apaisé
compris corps excusez moi vous venez
d'assister un naufrage terre
à
il s'appelait jean michel maire jean
michel mr 1926
2017 c'est un garçon qui aimait la vie
qui aimait les femmes
et puis un jour il a commis l'erreur la
plus grave s'aventurer dans une blague
sur les perroquets on l'a sorti de sa
cage et maintenant il va rentrer sous
pieds sous terre
six pieds sous terre d'ailleurs merci
jean michel mr applaudissements polis
[Applaudissements]